Hosni Mubarak maintained a firm grip on
power in Egypt for three decades until
finally in 2011 the people had enough
millions took to the streets hundreds
were killed but after 18 days
this new mobarak has decided to waive
the office of the president of the
republic the clouds reacted as they
heard the news that brought the man with
an iron fists down the military council
took the reins of power but it was from
the military the Mubarak had originally
wizened to power a former Air Force
chief in 1973 he led an air campaign the
regained the Sinai Peninsula from Israel
it has been a humiliating loss in the
1967 war President Anwar Sadat made him
Vice President Mubarak was just meters
away from siddharth when he was shot
dead in 1981 eight days later Mubarak
became president almost immediately he
implemented emergency laws giving the
state sweeping powers of arrests and
curving basic freedoms that would remain
in place for his entire presidency there
were a number of assassination attempts
like this one during a visit to Ethiopia
in the mid-1990s nearly 60 people were
killed in Luxor Mubarak cracked down
rounding up thousands of suspects from
the inside many Egyptians considered his
rule oppressive although he won four
elections there were allegations of
fraud but he continued to impress many
in the global political arena as he made
international diplomacy a cornerstone of
his rule
to secure a steady flow of oil supplies
into world markets and broker deals
between the Palestinians and the
Israelis
the Americans enlisted support of two
major allies Saudi Arabia and Egypt the
Saudi Kingdom used its financial power
and Egypt under Mubarak used its
political leverage to influence Arab
League decisions the strategy paid off
and he received crucial US military aid
worth billions of dollars but
unflinching Western support from a
barrack soon faded when the Arab Spring
began Mubarak was arrested and charged
with corruption and abuse of power in
2012 he was sentenced to life in prison
for failing to stop the killing of
hundreds of protesters after a retrial
Mubarak was acquitted in 2017 but his
legacy has endured with the current
regime led by another military figure
Abdul Fattah el-sisi
using similar hardline tactics to crack
down on dissent in order to stay in
power okay let's bring in another of our
correspondents Hashim al bara who is in
hat a province on the turkey-syria
border Hashim how do you think he'll be
remembered well Peter when you talk to
his own supporters there are mixed
reactions about the legacy of Hosni
Mubarak people would his supporters
would tell you that it's someone in
particular in the 80s and all the way
through the 90s managed in a way one
another to put Egypt on the map as a key
player particularly when it comes to
regional issues he was very instrumental
in all the talks about implementing a
permanent peace process with the
Palestinians and these valleys between
the Arabs and the Israelis and and that
he was a crucial player in the
international arena his opponents would
definitely tell you that this is some
one who fails to implement the reforms
he announced when he came to power in
1981 after the assassination of the
President Anwar Sadat and that he gave
sweeping powers to the to the into the
intelligence to the police and that his
last years were marred by corruption and
by this Bush to make his son Jamar
observe an Mubarak become the next
president of Egypt
so basically mixed reactions both
reactions more pronounced than ever
new pronouncement after the 2011
uprising in Egypt people basically tell
you that and Gopala
we have stability what came after
Mubarak was more for volatility
stability chaos and uncertainty he's
definitely going to be remembered as a
man who played a very important role
particularly in the eighties and the
nineties one of the most prominent Arab
leaders in that period as you're talking
to attention we're looking at library
pictures of him and I suspect we will
get back to them in the next minute or
so him with King Hussein of Jordan no
longer with us came with Saddam Hussein
of Iraq no longer with us given that he
survived so long in that top job in
Egypt and in the broader Middle East
what was it about him that gave him that
staying power that sticking power when
we talk about when he first became the
Egyptian leader well indeed when he came
to power in 1981 he came to power after
Sadat was assassinated and said that was
Mars of their life it was seen of what
of a war hero he's the one who was the
man who launched who who went to war
against Israel in 1973 and he was a man
who decided it's about time to start
peace talks with these
and they were all concerned about
instability in the region and and Hosni
Mubarak when he came to power who was
the fourth president of Egypt after the
1952 revolution so they were he was
aware about the fact that he was going
to lead a nation at the tumultuous point
in its modern history but he came about
with the idea of starting political
reforms and I think it will be
opposition about the early 80s he would
tell you those were the best moments and
times for Hosni Mubarak into the a late
first of all I think the biggest problem
he faced the challenge the falling up
there in terms of foreign affairs was
the war thing running in Iraqi war and
where Egyptians sided with former
president of Iraq and and then the
biggest challenges faced was the 1990
Gulf War when he decided to side with
the Americans and the Kuwaiti is in the
bush to evict Saddam Hussein the former
President of Iran from from Cuba Kuwait
halfway into the 90s that's when the
public sentiment started to shift from
supporting Hosni Mubarak into talking
about the need for genuine political
reforms giving a bigger say to the
opposition reaching out to the Muslim
Brotherhood the other opposition
political parties and also tackling the
most pressing problems that Egypt was
facing continue to face as we speak
which are unemployment poverty but he
failed and I think one of the biggest
problems is there was this sentiment
among the people about it was suddenly
seen as widely disconnected from the
pressing challenges another country
faced 2011 that was the moment when you
could really tell that the man was
losing touch with reality was a
thousands of people took to the streets
in Cairo in different parts of the
country they were met by brutality and
this bill
through establishment was hoping that he
would gather lesson and say I learned
from you and it's about time for me to
leave he was completely in denial it was
to his final speech he gave he was still
helping to be given another chance to
continue in his position as president of
Egypt and I think it was at that moment
when the military establishment decided
it's about time for him to be forced out
of power and then he he and then he left
and I think this should this would be
one of the things about his legacy if
you see someone who started with
offering promises but then for many
Egyptians it turned out that it was
starting Childress
to become more disconnected avoid
reality but I think one of the major
factors that led to his demise
politically work wasn't was the feeling
among many people that he was trying to
groom his son German Mubarak to take
over as president of Egypt that was that
was widely seen as a red line by the
Egyptian people
but above all by the military
establishment and I think this is one of
the main reasons why the army decided to
abandon him but Hashem if we say that he
started miss reading the optics or the
signals from the mid 90s he then carried
on and he still survived for another 13
14 15 years so what was it about his
mindset during that decade of time when
he was either miss reading what he was
being told or the people around about
him were miss reading it or they weren't
being honest with him as you know Peter
those were delicate times that only
called the Egyptians but for the Arab
well it was it was it was a time of
uncertainty economic decline the 1991
Gulf War and I think that was a time
when people were thinking that at least
we'll the stability that all these
governments were providing at beaders we
should aim for to
and tomorrow could be a better day and
first ago Barack was part of a system
that was prevailing in Egypt since 1952
which is a military establishment that
came to power after the military coup in
1952 our single military establishment
played a crucial role in maintaining
customer bollocks a grip of power that
started to changed particularly in 2005
and 2010 when he was extending his ban
daid would see that people are starting
to shift their own alliances who was the
opposition and people were voter turnout
in the elections were starting to
decline
don't schools she was hitting those
scores and I think he was just banking
one time he thought that because by the
way for many supporters of Hosni Mubarak
to consider him to be a war hero because
he was a commander of the Air Force 73
it was all the German his own people but
he took part in the in the war in 1973
and he thought the dam would help him
maintain his grip on power 2011 he
realized that millions of Egyptians all
of them were of the view was about time
for a genuine change too and with a new
political establishment and if you
remember we saw that momentum engulfing
the region spreading from Tunisia all
the way to Egypt Libya Yemen many
countries it was a feeling that this
would bring about a radical change in
the Arab world and pays the way for the
end of the political elites that has
been in power for decades not only in
Egypt Egypt but in different parts of
the world Hashim for the moment many
thanks if you're just joining us here on
al-jazeera just to recap for you our
breaking story at this hour Hosni
Mubarak the former Egyptian president
has died at the age of 91 he ruled the
country of course for 30 years let's
talk now - Timothy called us he's a
non-resident fellow at the korea
institute for
Middle East policy joining us on skype
from Cairo just share with us your
thoughts at this time I think it's
probably going to be a bit of a shock
too much the public plaza Mubarak was a
towering figure in Egypt for decades
during his rule and while he he's the
first president since since Nasser to be
able to leave office standing he he's
transitioned from living in disgrace
following his overthrow in 2011 to
actually watching a more brutal dictator
take his place and many Egyptians have
come to reminisce nostalgic ly about his
his period in power because of how badly
things have deteriorated since then
would it be fair to say Timothy that
outside the region
there was or there is a perception that
he was toppled as a result of the Arab
Spring and then was put behind bars but
it's maybe worth remembering he was
acquitted in 2017 yeah so there were
several cases brought against him one of
them stuck because the the paper
evidence was overwhelming regarding
corruption and embezzlement but the
other charges all were eventually
overturned including his conviction of
failing to prevent the killing of
protesters as it was worded so he no he
eventually got to live the rest of his
his life free with his family a lot of
people who died in the protests against
his rule lied didn't get that luxury why
was he so hated by so many people and so
well-liked by so many people I mean our
correspondent Hashim there was making
the point you know he spent 10 years
offering promises you could have said
the same thing about mr. Morsi who
followed him just for a year or so mr.
Morsi made lots of promises didn't
deliver on them Hosni Mubarak made
promises and then paid the ultimate
price well I think the case barukh you
he goes through a lot of stages in his
presidency given that he
was in power for nearly 30 years there
was enormous frustration with rising
cost of living a lot of people who were
falling into poverty in the latter years
of his tenure despite the economic
growth that Egypt was witnessing not
unlike what we're seeing today actually
in that respect and a lot of people
thought they were being left behind the
level of corruption was was quite high
and and very palpable very very visible
to the public as they saw some people
have enormous wealth and spend it in a
very public fashion whereas many others
struggled to make ends meet and I think
that that created a lot of tension and
he wasn't a particularly charismatic
character and so he didn't build this
kind of you didn't build the cult of
personality around him that would have
helped insulate him somewhat from those
criticisms I think that he in his later
years grew very detached from society
and him in the inner circle around him
really isolated themselves from the
grievances and much of the public and
thought that if they let them vent you
know on the side and in a very you know
in a very careful carefully limited
fashion that perhaps this could go on
indefinitely and they were caught by
surprise 2011 when things broke out the
way they did how approachable was he I
mean forgive me if that sounds like a
naive question in as much as there was a
point in the run up to the Iraqi
invasion of Kuwait when he was the go-to
guy in the Middle East in the same way
that King Hussein of Jordan was the
go-to guy in the Middle East
particularly for the Americans and the
Europeans and there was also a point in
the early to mid-90s when economic
analysts analysts of the Egyptian
economy and the broader Middle East
would say look we'll hang on there's
nothing particularly bad going on here
because the economic fundamentals in
Egypt at that point were okay so I mean
as far as being an interlocutor in a
region he was extremely he was extremely
prominent in that respect the u.s. saw
him as a reliable ally in terms of
promoting the kind of the the the order
in the region that they that they
that they had constructed he was a
valuable mediator with the Palestinians
on top of that he was willing to support
the the the 91 Gulf War not some but
refused to participate in the 2003 one
the economic situation stabilized after
the 91 Gulf War because an enormous
amount of Egyptian debt was forgiven
stabilizing their finances what we did
see was eventually some reasonable
levels of the economic growth in terms
of GDP growth but again poverty levels
also grew and so it was a very isolated
benefit which is something that we're
seeing again today where we're seeing a
GDP growth approaching six percent and
yet millions of people have fallen into
poverty in the last few years so this
this imbalance between what looked like
positive macroeconomic indicators and
underwriting and underlying challenges
for much of the public persist to this
day in Egypt he left office with the
largest hard currency reserves in the
country's history and today a [ __ ] tis
has already broken those numbers and has
even higher reserves than that but again
for normal Egyptians the situation
remains an economic challenge everyone
who's talking about him to us now today
Timothy is also talking in the same
breath about the Egyptian military our
Egyptian presidents doomed to fail when
they get too comfortable with the
specter of the military behind them and
then they then begin to ignore the
military and then the military almost by
definition feel the need to step in
because that's kind of what we've seen
with el Sisi well I think we have a very
limited sample size when it comes to
Egyptian presidents so it's hard to make
any sweeping statements about what's
normal or to be expected Gamal Abdel
Nasser and Anwar Sadat both those died
in office one of natural causes and one
was assassinated but neither had
anything to do with the militant
and Hosni Mubarak was overthrown but in
but the while the military participate
in that overthrow it was under enormous
pressure from the public to do so that's
not to say that they didn't see their
own interest in doing so because of
fears of Mubarak son taking over and
he's a figure that was outside the
military and also had been empowering a
civilian business elite that was that
was tied to the regime but we we have a
very limited number of examples to work
with with respect to Morsi there was
always tension between the Brotherhood
and the security apparatus that never
went away and so it was not really an
issue of getting comfortable so much as
that there was never comfort he might
have overestimated the extent to which
they would fall in line he almost
certainly did but I think that that
pathetic assumption on his part was
flawed